And today we're going to discuss a new
topic, which is bargaining with
incomplete information.
So incomplete information.
And you recall that earlier in the
course, we studied a model of
bargaining, but in that model we had
complete information. And when we
studied bargaining with complete
information,
we observed, so let's recall,
that with complete info,
we had no disagreement
and no delay.
So when the two sides were bargaining,
whenever there was an agreement to be
reached, whenever there was some
possibility for agreement, it was always
achieved,
and it was always achieved in the first
period. There was never any of this
costly delay. Uh but of course, in
reality, we see a lot of disagreement
and a lot of delay when we look at real
bargaining in practice.
And we argued that maybe the missing
piece of our previous model was this
very strong assumption of complete
information. The assumption that both
sides exactly understand the preferences
of the other side. And just to make this
a little more concrete, let's look at an
example,
let's say plea bargaining. So this is
common.
You might have a defendant
who's accused of a crime
and a prosecutor.
And before potentially going to trial,
they might negotiate some plea agreement
which says you don't go to trial and
instead you serve a certain amount of
time.
And here I think there's definitely a
role for incomplete information. So
let's put yourself in the role of the
defendant, and let's say you really want
to reach a plea deal. You don't want to
go to court. So you make a really
generous offer
to the prosecutor. You say, "Look, uh
I'll plead guilty and I'll serve 30
years to avoid going to court."
Now generally we would think making a
very generous offer would help you get
the offer approved. But what might the
what might the prosecutor think if you
say, "I'm happy to serve 30 years." Yes?
That you're super guilty or maybe the
evidence is really Yeah, the evidence is
really really strong. It's going to be
easy to to show in court. So there's
this perverse effect where a better
offer is more likely to be accepted, but
now a better offer might suggest, "Wait
a second, there's a reason she's giving
me a really good offer, and maybe I
actually don't want to accept it and I'd
rather go to court." So in this case,
the defendant has private information
about certainly their guilt, but maybe
more relevantly, how easy it is to prove
their guilt.
And the defendant, their their offer
maybe conveys information
about we'll just say guilt
or evidence of guilt or other things.
Now let's look at the other side. The
prosecutor may also have private
information. Let's say the prosecutor
also really wants to get a deal.
And the prosecutor says, "Look, I'll
give you a really generous deal. You
only have to serve 6 months in prison if
you plead guilty and then we don't have
to go to court."
That sounds like a great deal. Why might
the defendant be hesitant if they if
they received an offer like that, a
really generous offer by the prosecutor.
Yeah?
Exactly.
So this is I think the key question.
They don't just say how good is the
offer, they say, "What is the quality of
the offer tell me about the other side's
information? And maybe they just have no
So maybe I should go to court even
though this offer seems really good. So
here the prosecutor's offer
might convey info about maybe the
evidence they have.
>> [snorts]
>> And and I think legal scholars certainly
think this is exactly why we often see
disagreement and delay in bargaining,
because the kinds of offers that you
might make to try to reach agreement can
convey information that make it harder
to reach an agreement.
So today we're going to look at
uh
two general classes of bargaining games.
And
I think it's helpful at first to
distinguish
two different situations.
Signaling and screening.
So so far we already talked about
signaling games last class, where
someone might choose a level of
education to try to signal their ability
as a worker.
And more generally in signaling games,
what distinguishes them is that the
first mover
has private information.
So when the first mover, the player who
takes an action first, has private
information, their action is going to
convey something about their private
information. So their action might
reveal or convey information.
And when the first mover is strategic,
they're going to think through how their
action might convey information, and
that's going to affect their choice of
action.
In screening,
uh
it's the second mover
that has private information.
So you might say, "Oh, well, the first
mover, they're going first, they don't
have any private information. Private
information doesn't have much of a
role." But it still has a role
because what the first mover is
potentially going to do
is they're going to choose their action
anticipating that the response to their
action conveys information that the
other side has.
So if I make an opening offer to you,
and and your choice whether to accept or
reject that opening offer conveys to me
information that you have. So here
there's signaling information. Here you
might call they're kind of fishing for
information. They're they're choosing an
action so that the response to that
action conveys information from the
other party. So maybe I'll say
fishing for information.
And the formal term screening, I guess
the first mover I should say is the one
And the term screening comes to the idea
that your response, I'm the first mover,
your response to my action screens you
and distinguishes different players with
different private information. So it's a
screening mechanism. I might offer
something to you.
Um you know, I might say, "Oh, you
really want this? Well, let me offer it
to you for a high price." And that will
screen out people who actually want it
and are willing to pay a high price from
people who are not. That's that's where
the term screening comes from.
So today, we're going to study
bargaining with incomplete information.
We're going to look at both the cases of
signaling and screening, and we're going
to do it all within a canonical
framework of just a buyer and seller
negotiating over the price of a good. Of
course, these ideas can be applied much
more generally, but
these games are a bit harder to analyze
than the ones we've done before, so we
want to stick to a very simple model to
begin with, but the lessons extend a lot
more broadly. So today, we're going to
look at a buyer and a seller.
And they're going to be bargaining over
the price at which they exchange the
good.
So we have our buyer and our seller. The
buyer has some value
V for the good, and we're going to make
different assumptions about who knows V
and who doesn't, but it's always going
to be called V. So this is how much the
buyer is willing to pay for the good.
And the seller has some cost
C.
Uh I should point out here that it's
just nice to use V and C and think of C
as a cost, but another interpretation of
the cost of the seller is how much they
value the item. Because remember the
cost C is what the seller loses when
they give up the item. And we can
interpret that utility loss in two ways.
Either they actually have to produce the
item at a cost in order to give it to
the other player, or they actually like
it themselves, and when they give it up,
they lose that. So we'll call it a cost
C, but you could also think of it as the
seller's value. It's just this way when
I say value, we know we're talking about
the buyer.
So what are their utilities? Well, if
they exchange at a price of P,
then the buyer's utility is V minus P.
They get value V from the good because
they're exchanging, but they have to pay
a price P to the seller.
And then the seller's utility
is P minus C, because the price P is
what goes to the seller. The seller gets
P dollars, but has to bear the cost C
either of producing the good or of
losing it.
And then if there's no exchange,
well now we just say each player gets
utility zero because the good is not
exchanged and money does not change
hands. So here we have
UB equals zero and US equals zero.
Now let's
to kind of
make some progress here at first,
let's first think about well,
if we think we're going to if if we
might see exchange, what are the
possible ranges of prices at which
exchange takes place?
Well, at least if if V and C are known,
so let's start with this case. So case
one is kind of the easy case.
Case one is where V and C are publicly
known.
So this is kind of the case that we
studied earlier in the course. This is
actually a case of complete information.
So let's review this and then we'll
contrast it with with the other cases.
Well, if V and C are public,
there's something we can say, "If trade
happens at P,
we can say a lot about what what P must
satisfy, right? If if if V and C are
public, let's suppose we see the players
trade at price P. What do we know about
how P compares to V and C?
Yeah. P has to be greater than C, but
less than V. Okay, and can you explain
why? Yeah. The reason is we need V minus
P to be at least zero, otherwise the
buyer would choose not to exchange.
Exactly right. And P minus C has to be
greater than or equal to zero for the
seller to want to exchange. Exactly
right. So, we kind of have two
constraints, right? If they exchange at
price P, this is voluntary exchange. It
only happens if both players agree to
it, cuz either player can walk away and
say no. So, the only possible prices we
could exchange are prices P that make
each player weakly better off than their
outside option of just walking away. So,
if we trade at price P, we must
immediately have Maybe I'll write it in
two separate inequalities. P greater
than equal to C and P less than equal to
V.
This inequality is because of the
seller, so maybe I'll put S here. If P
were less than C, the seller would never
want to trade at price P.
And this comes from the buyer.
If the price were greater than V, the
buyer would simply walk away.
So, we immediately see from this that if
trade is going to occur,
we must have C smaller than P smaller
than V, and in particular that means C
must be smaller than V. So, let's assume
that C is strictly smaller than V. This
is a common assumption to rule out kind
of the trivial case. Uh if V is strictly
smaller than C, then there's no way we
can ever have exchange.
And if V equals C, well then we could
have exchange, but it's only going to be
at the price P equals C equals V, and
then there's no change in utility and
it's not a very interesting case. So,
this is where uh sometimes what we say
here is there are gains from trade.
You know, some people say this is what
economics is all about, gains from
trade. Why are there gains from trade
here? Well, when the good moves from the
seller to the buyer, the buyer's utility
goes up by V and the seller's utility
goes down by C.
And because V is bigger than C, it's
possible for there to be a price such
that both players are better off. The
The gain to the buyer is bigger than the
loss to the seller when we exchange.
So, let's In this case, we've done it
before, but let's just go through the
analysis. We need to make a choice, our
modeling choice, about the order in
which the players move.
So, I think it's pretty standard, at
least in practice, when we see
um
certainly in stores, we see sellers
often post a price first. You could
maybe walk in and offer your own price,
and in one-off negotiations that does
happen, but let's think of the case
where we have, you know, many goods, we
tend to see it done this way. So, let's
make our timing
be that the seller proposes a price.
And then the buyer,
of course, it's always the potential
buyer, they don't have to actually buy,
observes the price P that's offered, and
then chooses whether to accept or not.
Accept the offer or not, meaning buy or
not buy.
So, maybe we'll say buy,
And if we want to draw this in extensive
form, just as a This is maybe this is a
good review as we're getting closer to
the exam. So, we have the seller here.
Now, it's a little tricky cuz the price
can take any value,
say any non-negative value. So, we you
know, there's infinitely many prices the
seller can offer. It's always a little
hard to write that down,
uh but maybe we'll write it something
like this.
I'll call this the price P.
Uh
I'm visualizing this as, you know, the
the full range of prices the seller can
offer.
Maybe I'll put this distinguish one
here.
And then the buyer sees the price
and makes a binary choice. I'll call it
A and R, accept or reject. Accept means
buy, reject means not buy.
And then let's make sure we get the
payoffs here.
Remember V and C are known, these are
just parameters of the game. So, if the
price P is accepted by the buyer, then I
think we put buyer first, so let's do
buyer utilities first. The buyer is
going to get V minus P, the seller is
going to get P minus C.
And over here it's just going to be zero
zero because both sides reject.
So, now
let's try to understand
let's try to solve for a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium of this game. Notice we
can use the the solution concept of
subgame perfect Nash because there's no
private information, because this is a
game of complete information. Once we
move to incomplete information, we have
to use perfect Bayesian equilibrium. But
for this, we can just use subgame
perfect Nash.
So, let's look for subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium.
Uh
What do we want to do?
Well, the trick with a game like this is
we always work backwards. In fact, with
this game we can apply backward
induction, right? So, let's start with
the second player. This is the buyer.
And we can ask
well, what offers is the buyer going to
accept?
Well, the buyer can either get zero or
take the offer. So, they're going to
accept an offer if their total utility
from accepting the offer is at least
zero.
So, the buyer is going to accept
Maybe I'll use double arrow to say if
and only if
V minus P
is greater than equal to zero.
This is the utility of accepting the
offer.
This is their utility of rejecting the
offer, and they're going to accept if
the utility from accepting is better
than the utility of rejecting.
There's a little flexibility if this
equals exactly zero, but you know, kind
of a common theme when you're looking
for equilibria, it's often better to
break ties this way and say that when
indifferent, they accept. It tends to
um make sure the sender
uh deals with some existence problems
for the sender's choice.
Uh well, another way of saying this is
they're going to accept if and only if V
is greater than equal to P.
And anticipating that, we can now go to
the first mover, the sender, seller.
And what is the seller going to do? If
they anticipate the buyer will accept if
and only if V is greater than equal to
P,
uh well then what price do they want to
offer?
Yeah.
Well, then they should just offer the
highest price.
The highest price possible that will be
accepted, right? And in this case,
that's just P equals V.
Notice here we're using our assumption
that C is less than V.
Cuz if V was less than C, they might not
actually want to offer V because that
wouldn't cover their costs, but under
our assumption that V is at least as big
as C, then the seller is going to make
offer the highest price that will be
accepted. That's P equals V, and then we
can see what are the utilities going to
be.
Well, the buyer is going to get V minus
V. The first V is their value, the
second V is actually the price, but it
equals the value.
So, that's going to be zero.
And the sender is going to get
V minus C.
V here is playing the role of the price
minus the cost, and this is strictly
greater than zero.
Uh sometimes terminology might say,
remember we called V V minus C, we said
there's gains from trade between because
V is greater than C. We sometimes think
of V minus C is the potential gains from
trade. This is the the amount of utility
that can go up if they trade. And here
we sometimes say the seller has fully
extracted the gains from trade. Maybe
I'll say this, or maybe I'll say the
seller
gets all gains from trade.
Right, in this game we can think of
this, remember before we studied this
game, split the dollar?
V minus C is basically the dollar. This
is the potential gains that are on the
table.
It's going to be split in some way
between the buyer and the seller.
And in this case, the buyer gets none of
it, and the seller gets all of this. And
this is because the seller gets to move
first, anticipating the way the buyer is
going to respond.
So, now that we've
kind of reviewed this case, let's now
introduce incomplete information. So,
let's make different assumptions about V
and C, unless there's any questions uh
So, we're going to start with I
mentioned over here there's two cases,
signaling and screening. And let's be
really clear here. This game didn't
involve any signaling or screening.
Because the sen- the seller and the
buyer, or in this case the seller,
didn't have any private information. So,
the price they offered didn't convey
anything, and this didn't fit into our
framework of signaling and screening,
but now we're going to move into that
case.
So, let's start with
screening.
So,
what we want to imagine is that the
buyer,
we're still going to assume that the
seller makes an offer.
But now we're going to assume that the
buyer has private information. Buyer,
but not seller.
Let's be a little more precise.
The seller doesn't have any private
information, so let's assume that the
the cost C of the seller is publicly
known. This is commonly known, everyone
observes this. So, we'll say
the cost C
is known,
or is public.
What's not known is the buyer's
valuation, how much the buyer values the
good.
But V
is private information of the buyer.
So, this fits into our screening setting
because it's the second mover, the
buyer, who has the private information.
The first mover, the seller, doesn't
have any private information. But as we
said before, the second mover's response
to the first mover's action is going to
convey information. In this case,
the first mover's action by the seller
is to offer a price.
The buyer then is going to choose
whether or not to buy at that price. And
that's going to reveal information about
the buyer, and in particular it's going
to screen or separate different kinds of
buyers. Because buyers who value the
good more are going to choose to accept
the offer, and buyers who value the good
less are going to choose not to accept.
So let's try to
model this. Well,
if C is known, that's just a number that
everyone knows. We don't have to say
anything more about that. But V, because
it's private information of the buyer,
we have to specify the seller's beliefs
about this quantity V. So let's make
kind of our standard assumption. Let's
say that V is uniformly distributed.
This just makes the algebra a bit
easier. It's uniform over
0 1.
It's a random variable. It's uniformly
distributed over 0 1.
And now to make things interesting,
let's assume that C, this public number,
is somewhere between 0 and 1. Cuz if C
was greater than 1, well we'd never have
trade. And if C was less than 0, well
we'd always have trade. It's not so
interesting. So let's assume
C greater than 0
is known.
I want to highlight this cuz I think
it's often a source of confusion when
people see a variable, a letter, they
think somehow it's not known. It's just
playing the role of a number. Everyone
knows it. Maybe it's 0.3. Maybe it's
0.7. But we're just using a abstract
symbol C to make it things a little bit
clearer. Yes. Does the seller know the
distribution of V? Yes. So when we say
that V is uniform, uh everything we're
saying here is common knowledge among
the players. So not only is it
distributed according to the uniform
distribution, but if we're really
precise, the seller knows that the buyer
knows that the seller knows that and so
on. Everything I've said here is common
knowledge. Yeah. Good question.
Okay?
Great. So now let's uh C greater than 0
and I also see, let me be more precise,
it's 0 less than C less than 1.
Okay. So now let's look at the seller's
problem.
Let's suppose the seller offers a price
of P.
Well, if they offer a price of P, who's
going to buy? Well, the buyer is going
to buy if and only if their value is at
least P.
So then
buyer accepts or buys, kind of use those
interchangeably,
if and only if
V
is greater than equal to P.
And let's be a little more precise here.
What kind of price might the seller
reasonably offer? It doesn't make sense
them to offer more than one. If the
price they charge is more than one, it's
never going to be accepted. And if it's
less than 0, well that means they're
paying you to get the good. That doesn't
make sense. So let's focus on a price
offer that's between 0 and 1.
And we can show that they would never
want to offer a price outside that
range.
Okay?
Now, the buyer is going to accept or buy
buy if and only if V is greater
than equal to P.
Well, let's think about how likely this
is. Because as the seller, all I care
about is when I offer you a price of P,
what is the probability that you
actually buy at that price?
So we can think of we can draw a little
graph.
Here's 0. Here's 1.
The buyer's value is uniformly
distributed over this interval.
The seller is
choosing some price P in this interval,
and the buyer is going to buy if and
only if their valuation lies above P. So
lies in this segment.
Because we're working with the uniform
distribution, the probability that the
buyer's value lies in this segment is
just the length of the segment. That's a
nice convenient property of the uniform.
So the probability
here is just
1 minus P.
So now we can compute
what is the seller's profit from
offering a price of P?
Well, as usual, profit is
the number or the probability that you
sell the item times the profit you get
when you do sell it. So if they do sell
it,
their profit is going to be
P minus C. Because the buyer buys at
price P, pays P to the seller, but
remember the seller has to pay a cost C
to sell it.
But we have to multiply that by the
probability that the buyer actually
sells it.
Um or that the buyer actually buys it,
sorry. Um
which
is here the probability that V is
greater than equal to P.
And from what we said down here,
this is just 1 minus P.
So as usual, we have the two
counteracting forces. When we raise the
price P, we being the seller,
we earn more per item,
but we reduce the probability that the
item is purchased.
And that's the fundamental trade-off. If
you set the price really high, it's
great when someone buys, but they're not
very likely to buy.
And if we just use calculus or use our
trick here, uh we can see that the
solution
is going to be 1 plus C
over 2.
Now I've framed everything here, and
let's just do a sanity check as we
always do. If C increases, the price is
increasing, and that should make sense.
If the cost of something is more
expensive to produce, the price of
producing it uh the price that the
seller charges is going to be higher.
Now, this all seemed maybe, you know,
it's we talked we used some fancy words,
incomplete information, but it turns out
this is really equivalent to a very
classical kind of econ 101 problem. And
I want to show the connection here. Um
so
I know some of you have taken econ,
maybe some of you haven't, but if we
just look at the classic
supply and demand curve,
we have price on this axis and
quantity on this axis.
Uh well, we can think of a seller facing
a buyer like this as facing a demand
curve
that looks like this.
Because if I'm the seller,
whatever price P I offer,
we already said from our calculation
over here
that the buyer is going to buy with
probability 1 minus P.
So I'm effectively facing
a demand curve that looks like this.
If I charge a price of 1, the buyer
never buys. So demand is 0.
If I set a price of 0,
the buyer always buys, which means their
probability of buying is just 1. That's
my demand here.
And if I set an intermediate price of P,
well then the buyer buys with
probability 1 minus P, and it's this
point along the demand curve. So as
usual, in economics we see a downward
sloping demand curve. The lower the
price I offer as the seller, the more
likely the buyer is to buy. Now I'll
highlight I'll say up front that
normally we think of Q as the number of
units purchased, not the probability of
purchase. But if we're facing a
population of say 100 people,
we can reinterpret this probability,
where a half probability of buying now
means in expectation 50 out of the 100
people in your town are going to buy. So
we can reinterpret quantity as
Let's reinterpret it here as probability
of buying
times
the number of people.
Up here I just assumed there was a
single buyer, but the math doesn't
really change if you just multiply
everything by 100. Say there's 100
people. And here we see the connection
with, if you've taken econ and we talk
about the monopolist pricing problem,
this is exactly what they're doing. Of
course, I need one more thing on the
figure. I need the cost, because that's
also relevant to the
the monopolist. So let me put the cost C
here.
And
we can see
is this box here
represents the monopolist profit.
Why?
Well, the height of the box is P minus
C.
That's what we had up here for the
profit per unit.
The width of the box
is 1 minus P. It's determined by the
value of the demand curve at the price P
that's offered.
So that represents the probability of
sale.
And therefore, what's the seller's goal?
They want to move this price up and down
and choose the value that makes this box
have the largest possible area.
And it turns out that this is maximized
when the box is a square.
Uh and that's actually what happens
here. When P star equals 1 plus C over
2,
uh then
let's just observe this.
If P star
equals 1 plus C over 2,
then that means
P star
minus C
That's right.
equals 1 minus C over 2.
So I have 1 plus C over 2. I'm
subtracting C.
But since I'm dividing by 2, I can
subtract 2 C on the top.
And then I get 1 minus C over 2.
And then what is my demand?
1 minus
Did I did something wrong here.
Yes.
We know what the answer has to be. Let's
see. Uh we'll write it out more
carefully.
Maybe we can write this as 2/2
minus
1 + c over 2.
And now it's clear 2 - 1 is 1 - c we get
1 - c over 2.
So, this is at p* the height of the box
is 1 - c over 2
and the width of the box is also 1 - c
over 2 and we get a square.
That's a special property of the uniform
distribution. So, one final comment is
when we drew the connection between the
demand curve figure and the incomplete
information figure, the distribution of
the buyer's value exactly corresponds to
the shape of the demand curve. So, when
we draw different demand curves in econ
classes, one interpretation of that is
it corresponds to different
distributions of values in the
population.
A demand curve shifting out means more
people are willing to buy at a given
price, which means the distribution of
values in the population tends to be
higher.
Okay, but this was all still kind of a
review. Let's now move into uh the
incomplete information case.
Uh or the a more complicated incomplete
information case. So, let's go
maybe back over here.
So, before what we assumed is that
why what one question here is to say why
does the buyer care why does the seller
care about the buyer's valuation?
They care because the buyer's valuation
affects whether they buy.
But it doesn't affect how costly it is
for the seller to produce the item.
But there's a lot of cases where the
buyer's private information, so let's
say say this is another case, it's the
case of interdependent it's called
interdependent values
in the notes.
Interdependent
values.
And this is the case where the buyer's
private information
is relevant not just to how much the
buyer values the good
but the cost to the seller of providing
the good.
So, the buyer's private information is
about
v and c.
And this might be a bit strange. Why
would the buyer know how costly it is
for the seller to produce the item?
But there's a few classic
cases here. Uh does anyone know what's
sort of a classic case where the buyer
might have private information that's
relevant to both what the buyer gets out
of the exchange and also the cost to the
seller of making the exchange.
Yeah? Like is it possible that the buyer
would like value the good more and know
that it costs more for the seller to
provide the good?
Yeah, that's um
I think that's possible. Yes, um
Yeah, I think we're that's kind of along
along the right track. Yeah. Uh there's
one kind of classical application that
everyone talks about. Um
so, this is health care.
Health insurance.
And then I'll give you one more example
that's a bit closer to what you
suggested.
Health insurance. What does the buyer
know that's relevant to both v and c in
the context of health insurance?
Yeah?
Their own health status, right? The
buyer is here an individual. They're
buying insurance. This is one reason why
we see the government quite involved in
health insurance and the reason why
health insurance markets, unfettered
private markets, tend not to work well
precisely because of this issue. Because
the buyer has private information
that's relevant both to how much they
want the insurance but also to how
costly it is for the seller to provide
insurance to them.
So, what the buyer knows
their health status.
Of course, this is a gross
simplification, but in short you might
think someone who's healthy has a lower
v and a lower c. If I'm healthy, I don't
care about insurance as much and also
insurance is cheaper to provide to me
because I rarely go to the doctor and
the insurance company doesn't have to
pay much.
On the other hand, someone who's quite
unhealthy
uh is going to value insurance a lot
more. They're going to go to the doctor
a lot and get a lot more out of the
insurance, but that's also going to be
more costly for the insurer because the
insurer has to pay every time every time
they go.
Now, health insurance markets sometimes
try to mitigate this effect by offering
different prices based on different
observable characteristics. Like it may
be that based on your price, older
people tend to charge more they charge
more for health insurance than younger
people, but they still use the
additional private information you have.
Not all people who are 75 have exactly
the same health and they usually have
private information about how healthy
they are.
Um so, this can create a problem which
is often known as adverse selection.
And this term actually it's used in
economics a lot, but it actually was
first the term was first coined by
people who worked in insurance and noted
this phenomenon uh and then economists
subsequently studied it. Um
So, let's uh
let's look at quite a maybe a stylized
model of this.
So, let's represent the population of
the buyer
uh
the cost of providing insurance to the
buyer is going to be uniform over 01.
So, we can think of c as being kind of a
measure of the health uh of the buyer.
Uh I guess a higher c is someone who is
less healthy because it's more costly to
provide them insurance.
And then we want there to be some
relationship between c and v. So, let's
assume that v is equal to alpha + beta c
where
alpha is greater than equal to zero
and beta is
strictly greater than zero.
So, maybe it's helpful to
kind of draw a picture here to see
what's going on.
We have c, we have v.
C is uniformly distributed between
zero and one.
And v is alpha + beta * c. So, let's put
alpha here
and alpha + beta here.
And notice that when c equals zero, v
equals alpha.
And when c equals one v equals alpha +
beta.
So, we can think of people as kind of
lying along
uh this line
that looks like this.
We could have a more complicated model
where
maybe there's your cost doesn't directly
pin down your value and vice versa.
There might be some noise here, some
hetero individual heterogeneity, but
here in this really simple model,
everyone kind of lives along this line.
Here we have the healthiest people who
only get a value of alpha from the
insurance but only cost the insurer
zero. And then as you move along the
line, we have the least healthy people
who
uh cost one to the insurer to insure but
get utility alpha + beta from the
insurer.
In reality, we might need a
two-dimensional model, maybe health and
how rich you are and uh maybe everything
would be filled in and we'd have a
distribution, but we're going to
restrict just to this line to make
things um more concrete. And because c
is uniform, that means people we're
imagining people are uniformly
distributed along this line.
Yes. Just trying to understand this
qualitatively. How does someone
get a lot of value having the insurance
but not cost a lot or vice versa? Um it
could be. So, let's you know, wealth
would be the easiest case, right? So, uh
someone who is really rich might be
willing to pay a lot. So, what is value?
Yeah, sort of gets into what does value
mean? Let's say I go to the doctor and
fix my toothache. How much am I willing
to pay to fix my toothache? I might be
willing to pay less than someone else
even though that's it's fixing the same
toothache. So, the cost to the insurer
is just literally how much does the
doctor get paid and the facility to
perform the operation. But certainly
different people in the population would
be willing to pay very different amounts
for the same operation. A billionaire,
you know, would would tend to be willing
to pay more than someone who doesn't
have any money. Um so, in this model
we're not sort of taking into account
that that effect. We're looking at kind
of a simplified model where there's a
one-to-one relationship between
uh cost and value. Uh but yeah, I guess
the the way to think about value is
value is about your individual
willingness to pay. Because remember
going back to here
this this is almost the definition of
value. If your value is v, it means
you're willing to pay any amount up to v
to get that item.
And some people are willing to pay a lot
more for this for something that has the
same cost.
Yes, question. So, it's it's like not
necessarily true that a plus that alpha
+ beta is greater than one?
So, like are there any constraints that
would make alpha + beta greater than
one? Or in the real world, is it
possible that alpha + beta is less than
one?
I see. Um
Yeah, probably
uh
No, I think it could sort of
go either way. So, I guess one example
would be
>> [snorts]
>> let's think of a there there might be a
a very cheap surgery that really
improves my quality of life.
Uh
so, in that case the value that I get
out of that surgery, the willingness my
willingness to pay, might be much much
higher than the cost of producing that
surgery. Right? On the other hand, it
might go the other way. There could be a
really expensive new treatment that
doesn't really help me out very much.
And it may be hugely expensive to
provide this treatment, but the utility
gain and my willingness to pay for that
treatment might actually be quite low.
So, I think in general you could have
either ordering between V and C sort of
depending on the the context that you're
in. I mean, this is a very stylized
model. I'm not saying
you know, if we wanted to really
directly conduct health care policy,
we'd have to use a more complex model,
but just to convey the ideas I want to
do that. But, yes, I think there could
be and in fact this is an issue
when people have full insurance and they
don't have to pay to go to the doctor,
they sometimes
go to the doctor and get procedures that
are extremely expensive to provide, but
don't actually help them that much
because they don't have to pay. And
that's one kind of issue with insurance
markets.
Any other questions on this?
Okay, so now let's uh try to work
through
uh
an an analogous problem is over there.
We still have the seller choosing to
post a price, but now what's different?
Now
it's only going to be the high value
people who buy at a given price. But,
what's the key difference here? What's
going to be true about the people who
choose to buy the insurance? If I set a
price, only the people who value it more
than that price are going to buy. What's
going to be true about those people?
Who's going to buy my insurance? Yeah?
The people that have high costs as well.
The people that also have high costs.
And this is the fundamental idea of
adverse selection. If I go out into the
market and I say this is the price I'm
going to I'm going to offer, then the
people who are going to buy the
insurance are going to be the people who
are most expensive to insure. And that
can create uh problems. My kind of
favorite example of adverse selection is
in the 1990s, I don't know if told this
I tell this story every year, sorry, I
forget which year I told it. In the
1990s United or Delta one of the
airlines offered an unlimited flying
program
where you could fly forever
uh and it cost I think like $200,000 in
today's terms.
And Delta thought, well, most people
don't don't fly that much. $200,000
that's a lot.
It was a disastrous program for the
airline because there's some really
weird people who just like to fly. And
one guy just took the got took the
program and just flew first class around
the world every single day for the rest
of his life.
That's the example of adverse selection,
right? When you post a price, the person
who buys it is not the average buyer,
it's the person who really values flying
a lot. And this was a person who was
extremely costly to give an unlimited
flying license to. For me, probably
200k, the airline would make money on
me. Of course, my behavior would change
once I got it. Uh but in in this guy's
case, they lost a lot of money and they
ended up going to court and trying to
nullify the contract and it was this big
big mess. Um Okay, I guess another
adverse selection effect might be health
insurance. Another might be um
kind of
in financial markets, right?
Um
if I'm selling uh mortgage-backed
security and I don't know much about the
value of this mortgage-backed security
and someone's willing to buy it from me,
well, the fact that they're willing to
buy it probably means it's very valuable
and I'm not selling at a good price. If
they're not willing to buy it, uh then
it goes the other way. So, there's
always the problem. You always have to
think why is this person willing to buy
from me? And often if they're willing to
buy from me, it might mean I don't want
to sell it to them. And this is sort of
the fundamental issue of adverse
selection. If someone's willing to buy
an unlimited flight ticket for 200k,
uh maybe it's not a good idea to sell it
to them.
Okay, but let's uh let's now get into
kind of the the math here.
So, let's suppose I offer a price of P.
So, the seller
offers a price P.
Then the buyer buys
if and only if well, as before, their
value is greater than equal to P.
And now
instead of saying P is between 0 and 1,
let's say P is between
alpha and alpha plus beta.
Because again, if I charge a price below
alpha, no one's going to buy. And if I
charge it above alpha plus beta, sorry,
below alpha everyone's going to buy. And
above alpha plus beta, no one's going to
buy. So, we can just focus on on this
range.
Uh this range of values base.
So, receiver buys or the buyer buys if
and only if V is greater than equal to
P. Well, let's write that out. That
means alpha plus
beta C
is greater than equal to P.
Here I've just written out what what V
means. And now let's solve for C. For C
and we get C is greater than or equal to
P minus alpha over beta.
So, now we can compute
Let's actually go over to this board
here.
>> [snorts]
>> Let's compute
pi of P
which is what is the seller's expected
profit if they post a price of P.
Now, over here
we just wrote
P minus C times the probability that V
is greater than equal to P.
This part stays the same. This is the
probability they buy. But, now we have
to adjust P minus C.
Because now there's not one C, there's a
population of people. And the C that we
care about is not the average C in the
population, but it's the average C among
the people who buy.
So, we crucially need to compute
conditional expectation.
Maybe I'll write it this way.
P minus
E of C given that someone buys and that
means given that C is greater than equal
to
P minus alpha over beta over beta.
And then I'm going to multiply that by
the probability
that V is greater than equal to P or
maybe I'll write it the same way. I'll
write this as
C just to make the math a bit easier.
And now we can see this pretty clearly
in our in our graph. Let's say I post a
price of P
here.
Well, who's going to buy?
It's going to be people
along this segment of society. These are
going to be the sickest people, the
people who value insurance the most.
And a naive mistake that I think
historically some companies made is they
did this calculation just taking the
expected cost in the population.
Not recognizing that, well, I shouldn't
take the expectation over the entire
line.
I need to only take the expectation
among the people who are actually buying
my insurance. Or or in the airline
example, only among the people the
flying frequency of people who actually
buy an unlimited flying uh ticket.
So, now let's try to compute this
expectation.
Well, it turns out C is uniformly
distributed.
Down here, this is actually
P minus alpha over beta over beta.
So, I'm only focusing I'm only actually
selling to people who lie in this range.
And because C is uniformly distributed,
the average cost among people in this
range is just going to be the midpoint
of this range.
So, this is going to be
P minus
well, the midpoint of this is going to
be uh
1/2
times 1
plus
P minus alpha over beta.
>> [snorts]
>> So, it's still price minus
roughly cost, but now it's expected cost
conditional on buying. And then I'm
going to need to put this probability.
Well, this probability is just the
length uh the length of this segment
uh which is 1 minus P minus alpha over
beta.
Uh and let's
I think it's
we're interested in P. So, let's try to
do a little algebra to get P by itself
here.
So, in this we have P here
and we have minus 1/2 times 1 over beta.
So, we get P times 1 minus
1 over 2 beta
minus
1/2 times
alpha over beta.
So, now let's uh
analyze what's going on here.
This is
the purchase probability.
And this is
the profit per purchase.
Now, as usual, the purchase probability
is decreasing in the price. This is the
effect we always see. When I'm a firm
and I charge a higher price, fewer
people buy. That's very intuitive.
The new effect is here.
This is saying what profit do I make
per person who buys from me?
And notice that the coefficient on P
before
the coefficient on P was 1.
When I charged the price when I
increased the price by a dollar, every
time someone bought from me, the amount
of revenue I generated uh the the the
profit that I got from that person
increased by a dollar.
But, now
it doesn't increase by a dollar. It
increases by 1 minus 1 over 2 beta. So,
let's understand this. I raised my price
by a dollar,
I don't make a dollar more per person
I'm selling to. I only make 1 minus 1
over 2 beta more, which is strictly
smaller. I don't get the full dollar.
Why is that? So, why is this
less than 1?
Yeah?
Maybe because as you raise the price,
the people who will be buying it will
have higher beta, so their cost will be
higher.
Exactly right. So, this is reflecting
two effects. The first effect is yes,
when I raise my price by a dollar, my
revenue per patient increases by a
dollar. That always happens.
But, the second effect is when I raise
my price by a dollar, I change the
composition of the people who buy from
me.
I shift the people who buy from me to a
less healthy subset of people.
And on average those people are costlier
to serve.
And in fact, this is showing they're
costlier by exactly 1 over 2 beta.
Uh
Where does that come from?
Well, we can see here. These are the
segment of people I serve.
When I raise my price by a dollar,
I increase the left end point of this
segment by 1 over beta.
And therefore I I increase the average
of this segment by 1 over 2 beta. So
this is exactly the mark to 1 over 2
beta is the marginal effect of my price
on the average cost among the people who
buy from me.
More spec- precisely, it's the
derivative of this expression with
respect to P.
And
we can see
let's look at different cases of beta.
So what if beta is large?
And what if beta is
small?
So
if beta is very large,
adverse selection is not much of a
problem.
If beta is very large,
this curve is
very, very steep.
And
if beta is large, it says that there's
not a huge effect on the average cost
when I change the price.
Because if beta is large, it says that
C doesn't change much with V. Another
way I think the easiest way to see this
is to solve this expression for C as
we've done. And so note
C equals V minus alpha over beta.
So when I change the price by a little
bit, I'm changing by a little bit the
value of people who are buying from me.
And the question is if someone's value
changes a bit,
uh someone's value of buying from me
changes by a bit, how much does my cost
of providing to them change? And we see
it's exactly proportional to 1 over
beta.
So when beta is really, really large,
adverse selection is not much of a
concern.
So little adverse selection.
When beta grows small, then people who
value the item just a little bit more
are extremely costly to insure.
So we have
severe adverse selection.
And let's look at the case where beta
is
greater than 1/2.
Or I'm sorry, less than 1/2.
So this is the extreme case.
What happens if beta is less than 1/2?
What happens to this coefficient?
Yeah?
It's negative, right? So what does that
mean? I raise prices
and I actually earn less per person than
I did with the lower price.
What it says is if beta is less than
1/2,
the shift in the composition of people
who buy from me
more than outweighs the fact that I'm
charging a higher price.
And I'm actually earning less per
patient I serve.
And what that means, maybe we'll call
this
market breakdown.
Why? Well,
if beta is less than 1/2, then this is
decreasing in P.
And this is also decreasing in P.
So that shows my profit is certainly
decreasing in P
over the range
uh
alpha to alpha plus beta.
So
when I say market breakdown,
I guess the only possibility is
uh maybe what I mean is
screening is not possible.
Because the optimal price is either P
equals alpha or no sale.
If my profit is decreasing in P,
the only possible maximum of this
expression would be at P equals alpha at
the left end point. So I either have to
serve everyone in the market or serve no
one. And it may be optimal actually for
me to serve no one. But what it says is
there can't be a screening effect. I
can't charge an intermediate price and
get some people to buy and some people
not to buy. The only possibility is I
set the price low enough that everyone
buys from me
or I just don't uh sell at all.
Maybe we can interpret everyone buying
from me as kind of universal coverage,
right? We can't have a premium insurance
plan that only certain people buy. That
can never be optimal if adverse
selection is severe enough. Yes. And so
if you sell to everyone but at a price
alpha, is your profit supposed to be
zero? Is that what the math cancels
Uh it's going to depend on the values of
alpha.
So in some cases, uh so if you set the
price to alpha, you're going to get some
number. If that number is if your profit
is greater than than zero, that's the
optimum. If it's less than zero, you're
better off selling to no one. Oh, so
your point is just that if beta is less
than 1/2, then the only optimal like you
have to solve like
Yes, there's no interior solution.
Either I sell to everyone or I sell to
no one.
I mean, we could go more in into details
depending on the details of alpha and
beta, but basically we have a function
and
it's going like this.
So it's maximum is uh
at alpha equals uh zero. Yeah.
We have to be careful of sometimes
things can be negative. So uh yeah, when
I say it's okay, we have to be careful.
When we say it's decreasing in beta,
uh that's not true if one of these
expressions is negative. So let me make
the more precise statement that the
solution occurs either at alpha or beta
at alpha plus beta.
And so why does it make sense
[clears throat] that
you would sell to everyone?
Like if what what about beta makes it so
you could potentially make money from
selling to everyone?
Uh so whether it's profitable to sell to
everyone is really going to depend on
alpha.
What I what beta's controlling is what
happens when I slightly raise my price.
So when when when beta is very, very
small, it says adverse selection is so
severe that I would never want to sell
to only some people in the population
because by raising my price a little
bit, I'm actually earning less per
person because those people are so much
sicker.
So when that effect is really strong, I
don't want to be vulnerable to adverse
selection. I don't want to sell to the
subset of the population who value it
most. I either want to sell to everyone
or sell to no one.
And that's going to be controlled by
alpha, right? Alpha could be enormous.
If alpha is a million and C is pretty
small, then then I certainly want to
sell to everyone.
Um alpha is kind of about a level
effect. It's like is this a good market
to be in? Do I want to sell to people or
not? Beta is a marginal effect, which is
controlling what happens to my profit as
I slightly change my price. And it's
saying if beta is small enough, the
adverse selection effect is so strong
that I never want to slightly shrink the
set of people I sell to because the cost
among those people is going to be so
much higher. Yes, I mean. I'm thinking
about like real world examples where you
have insurance markets. Like I'm
thinking like disaster insurance where
like if you live in a certain area, like
you have to buy insurance or like if
you're like have health care like given
by your employer. Right. Like would that
be a case where like the you just end up
charging alpha and it like because of
the policy intervention, like the
insurance company charges alpha for
everyone?
Yeah, so I guess a separate issue that
comes up with disaster insurance is that
often disasters disasters are
correlated. So if you have a heart
attack, someone else isn't more likely
to have a heart attack. If you get hit
by a hurricane, everyone's often hit by
a hurricane. So often there's an issue
that these these disasters are too big
to insure.
Uh so often the state steps in and
provides the insurance because no
private company can do it. And then the
state puts in these uh these
regulations.
Um
uh I think really what's going on
yeah, in those cases, okay, there's a
lot going on with with disaster
insurance. Um in this case
here, um
I think
normally it with reasonable parameter
values, I mean, this is a very
simplified model. With reasonable
parameter values, when adverse selection
is bad, the solution is probably going
to be to sell to no one. Because you're
going to have if you have any really
healthy people
who are willing to pay a very low amount
for insurance. I mean, think about it.
Let's say
if I'm supposed to insure everyone in
the population, but I can only charge a
price that makes the healthiest people
willing to buy,
then that's probably not going to be
profitable for me. So I think what I
would say is in in realistic settings,
the alpha where markets break down, the
alpha is going to be small enough so
that there's not going to be a
sustainable
uh private insurance market. Of course,
there's a separate issue here that we
haven't we've there's a separate
question, which is how well can we
monitor people? So another thing that
could happen is you might impose very
strict health standards. You might say
there might be a functioning insurance
market, but only for people under 50.
And then people over 50 are just kind of
excluded from the market. And that
conditioning is not present is not
captured here. Or at least the
interpretation of this would have to be
after we conduct medical tests and after
we condition, and then beta might become
bigger. Yeah.
Uh
yeah, I think the
yeah, I think the insurance market the
the disaster insurance interesting, but
I think it's really a separate issue
because people don't really have private
information about how likely their home
is to flood. I mean, maybe if the
government has to use really blanket
policies and they're not fine-grained
enough, but at least in the private
market, I think there's not that's not
really an adverse selection issue. It's
really a too big to fail um issue. Yeah,
but it's an interesting question. And um
yeah, actually, one of my colleagues is
just writing a paper about uh this in in
Cali- California wildfire insurance and
looking at how insurers handle this.
Yeah, it's interesting.
Okay.
Let's uh
we've talked a lot about screening.
Let's now talk about signaling. And this
gets a little messy, so we're going to
have to work with an even simpler model.
And yeah, we should have time just to to
finish this off.
Okay. So now let's finally move to the
case of signaling.
So we're still with the seller and a
buyer. We're still in incomplete
information bargaining, but now it's the
seller who has private information.
And now we're going to say the seller
has private info
about V and C. So this this sort of
another canonical application where the
seller we said insurance is the
canonical case where the buyer has
private information that's relevant to
both V and C.
You can think of a setting where the
seller has private information about V
and C.
It's kind of a
classic story here.
Um used cars are kind of the classic
case and more generally used goods,
right?
Here I think it's important to think of
C
maybe not so much as a cost but more as
how much the seller values the good.
And the idea is if I'm going to buy a
used car, the seller of that used car
knows whether it's making a bad sound,
whether it's had a lot of accidents,
whether there's these problems.
Basically what they know is the quality
of the good.
And that quality,
unobserved quality, is relevant both to
how much the buyer values it and how
much the seller values it. But because
the seller has had the good for a while,
they know a lot more about it than you
as the buyer who come by and just try to
inspect your good.
Uh
and the classic case would be
used cars. So there's a very famous
paper
called The Market for Lemons
uh by Akerlof that he won the Nobel
Prize for
for identifying this issue and why used
car markets often don't work well. And
it's sort of the same classic thing that
we we said going back to the uh
defendant and the prosecutor, if someone
comes to you and says uh I can't sell my
used car but I'm going to give you a
really good deal. Here's a really good
deal, it's really cheap. You're going to
say wait, why is it so cheap? It's cheap
because it must be, you know, a lemon.
It must be that's another word for a car
that doesn't really work, right? Uh and
and for that reason these markets can
kind of break down.
Uh I think my financial example was
another good one, right? So um
mortgage-backed securities might be
another case where it's not clear which
side has more private information, it
sort of depends who they are. But in
some cases the holder of the
mortgage-backed security may have
private information that's relevant to
the value of this asset and the both the
buyer and the seller care about that.
Okay, so let's look at a really
simplified model
where we're going to say that the good
has quality
either L or H.
And here these are not numbers, these
are just uh labels. It's either low
quality or high quality.
But the quality of the good is relevant
to both the buyer and the seller.
So if it's a low quality good
then
and
I don't know. All these inequalities may
be confusing.
So if it's low quality
then
the seller's cost is CL and the buyer's
value is VL. If it's high quality, the
seller's cost is CH and the buyer's
value is VH. And we have all these
inequalities. For the seller, a low
quality item is less costly than a high
quality item. But we also want the
seller's cost to be lower than the
buyer's value for low quality item.
For a high quality item, the seller's
cost
is smaller than the buyer's value. So
there are potential gains from trade,
but again the buyer values it more when
it's high quality than when it's low
quality.
So there's kind of a string of of
inequalities here.
And now what we're going to look at is
price signaling.
I'm going to set a price to the seller.
The buyer is going to see that price and
infer something about the value of the
item. And then we want to try to solve
for an equilibrium with this. And we're
going to have to use uh perfect Bayesian
equilibrium here to analyze this.
Now we need to specify a prior
distribution
uh about the quality of the good. So let
me say a little bit more here. The
seller
knows quality.
The buyer doesn't know the quality, but
they just know the distribution of
quality in the population. And we'll say
that
uh we'll put pi here and 1 minus pi
here.
So the prior distribution is that
fraction pi of things are high quality,
fraction 1 minus pi of things are low
quality. The seller actually knows the
quality, the buyer does not.
And after observing the price
the seller is going to set a price. The
buyer sees the price and is going to
update their beliefs about the quality
of the item based upon the price.
So let's try to construct
you'll I think have more practice doing
these in the problem set, but we'll
start constructing
PBE in this game.
Perfect Bayesian equilibria. And as
usual we're going to separate into two
cases. We're going to look for a pooling
equilibrium and a separating
equilibrium.
On one hand we'll do pooling.
And the other is separating.
A pooling equilibrium means
sellers with high quality products and
sellers with low quality products both
sell at the same price.
So the price alone doesn't give away
whether it's high quality or low
quality.
So in a pooling equilibrium the seller's
strategy
So let's make sure we understand what's
going on here. What is the seller's
strategy in this game? We need to say if
the quality is low, what price do they
set? And if the quality is high, what
price do they set?
In a pooling equilibrium, these are
going to be the same price and we'll
call that price P star. And this is
going to be a parameter of the
equilibrium that we're going to try to
solve for.
What is the buyer's strategy? As I say I
think
writing down the strategies correctly is
often the hardest part of this. So what
is the strategy for the buyer in this
game?
Yeah? Can you find an expected value of
the quality
in some way or like You
You could, but let's um
let's not even think about optimality.
Let's just think what kind of object is
a is a strategy? Is it a number? Is it a
vector? Is it a function? Just what what
thing is it?
Uh what kind of mathematical object? I
think that's often the first step. Yeah,
in the back. Would it be either accept
or reject as a function of the price?
Exactly, as a function of the price that
the seller offers, exactly. So it's
going to be a function, maybe I'll call
it Q since we think of Q as quantity of
buying. Q from
uh maybe
if we don't restrict restrict the price
at all, well the seller can offer any
non-negative price, say between zero and
and uh
infinity not inclusive
to
well
maybe we'll call it zero one.
So Q we can think of this as the
quantity that they buy. They either buy
zero, that means they don't buy or
reject, or Q equals one, that means they
buy or accept the offer.
And
let's put
a graph here. We have VL.
We have VH.
Um and I want to try to kind of work up
gradually and and uh
try to build up an equilibrium.
So
the first I think useful observation
when we're trying to pin down the
equilibrium is to say, well, there are
some prices where we know what the buyer
has to do
whatever their belief is.
So let's think. The buyer's belief
is going to form a belief about the
quality of the item, right? And if
they're really pessimistic, they would
think the item is worth VL.
If they're really optimistic, they're
going to think the item is worth VH.
And as their beliefs vary, they're going
to value the item somewhere between VL
and VH depending on how likely they
think it is that it's high quality or
low quality.
But if they get offered a price below
VL, what are they going to do?
They have to buy.
Because even if they're certain the good
is low quality
this price is still lower than their
value for the good.
What if they see a price above VH?
They're never going to buy. Doesn't
matter even if they're certain the good
is high quality, it's not worth buying
because VH is smaller than the price. So
we immediately know that let's think of
Q over here, we're immediately going to
have one here
and zero here.
And the flexibility is going to be
between VL and VH. For a price between
VL and VH, whether they buy is going to
depend on their belief. Because if
they're certain it's high quality, let's
say there's a price in here, if they're
certain it's high quality they do want
to buy.
If they're certain it's low quality they
don't want to buy. And it's going to
depend on what their what their belief
is, right?
Okay.
What else can we say when we're looking
for an equilibrium?
Well
remember PBE, we have to have
sequential optimality for the seller,
sequential optimality for the buyer, and
then base consistency for the buyer.
Now base consistency only pins down the
buyer's beliefs when they see a price
that they're supposed to see in
equilibrium. It only pins things down on
path.
So what is going to be on path in this
equilibrium?
What price are they expecting to see in
this equilibrium?
Just P star.
That's the only price they should see.
Right? Because that's what the low type
seller is offering and that's what the
high type seller is offering. So So they
see a price of P star,
so let's
what belief do they form?
They apply base rule. What happens when
they see a price of P star?
Yeah.
Well, I mean, given pi, we would have
intuition about like it's a low type or
a high type, and
like we would know which one of those
has higher probability
indicating whether the car is is
actually low type or high type.
Right, but here we're looking for a
pooling equilibrium, right? Where both
the high type seller and both the low
type seller and the high type seller
sell at P star.
So when I see the price of P star, what
is my belief?
Yeah.
That it's high type with probability pi.
Right, it's just the same as the prior,
right? So if everyone is charging a
price of P star,
I I keep my beliefs, my beliefs stay
exactly what they were at the prior. I
have no reason to update my belief. I
mean, formally I'm applying base rule,
but when I update my beliefs, they're
the same as they were before because
everyone offers the price of P star. The
price doesn't really reveal anything.
So maybe I'll say P star belief
pi
on H.
Now, if I believe the item is
high with probability pi,
then the value I assign to it, maybe
I'll call the value V star, is going to
be pi * VH
+ 1 - pi
* VL.
That's my expected evaluation of the
item
given this that my belief here is pi.
All right?
So we're kind of building this up. We're
looking for an equilibrium where the
seller charges a price of P star. We
know that the buyer's valuation has to
be this.
And we want the seller to sell the item
at a price of P star. So what must be
true about P star relative to V star in
this equilibrium?
Yeah.
P star equals V star. It could equal V
star, but it has to be at least weakly
smaller than V star. You might It could
be It could be V star. So let's put V
star in here.
And P star is going to have to be
somewhere
smaller than V star.
Okay?
And we know that at a price of P star,
let's look for an equilibrium where the
buyer does buy at a price of P star.
Now, the trick for these equilibria
is often you want to make deviations as
unattractive as possible. So we want to
make this an equilibrium. That means you
want to make sure the seller doesn't
want to offer a price different from P
star.
To make sure the seller doesn't want to
offer a price different than P star, it
better be that the buyer never buys if a
price is strictly higher than P star.
So if I see a price higher than P star
as a buyer, I'm not going to buy, and
that way the seller won't want to
deviate to this. So let's look for an
equilibrium
that goes like this.
Seems like a natural
equilibrium.
If I see any price that's weakly below P
star as a buyer, I buy.
And if I see any price above P star, I
don't buy.
Now, we have to specify beliefs. I think
the easiest thing is to say
uh well,
say
doesn't even
doesn't even matter, but sometimes this
is a good trick.
Let's say that if I see any price
strictly below P star, here I have a lot
of flexibility in what the beliefs are
cuz we're off path,
but I know that the buyer is buying, so
to make that optimal, let's just say
they believe the good is certain to be
high quality. Doesn't really matter what
I do here.
If they see a price strictly greater
than P star,
they believe it's low quality and don't
buy.
And if they see a value a price of
exactly P star, well, we know what they
have to believe. They have to believe
the good is high quality with
probability pi because this price is on
path, and therefore base rule can be
applied.
For these lower prices and these higher
prices, I'm totally flexible in how I
choose the buyer's beliefs because these
are off path, and if I tried to apply
base rule, I would divide by zero, and
therefore base rule doesn't have any
bite.
Um
Okay, so I think we're good, but I think
we need one more constraint. So
we've we've defined P star.
We've said P star is between VL and V
star.
This means that the buyer is willing to
buy.
Uh I think there's one more potential
issue
with this equilibrium. So let's go
through it. We've checked
and yeah, I'll just write this here.
We've checked belief consistency
because here the buyer believes it's low
quality, they cer- uh believes it's high
quality, they certainly want to buy.
Here they believe it's low quality, they
certainly don't want to buy.
Here they believe its expected quality
is V star, and they're will therefore
willing to buy at a price of P star. So
base consistency is right.
Receiver optimality, RO, all right,
receiver buyer optimality
is good, but I think there's one more
issue with seller optimality. So we have
to check, does the seller ever want to
deviate to offering
a different price?
Well, the trick is always to say what is
the most
attractive
deviation. Would the seller ever want to
charge a price a lower price here?
No, because they're already selling it
with certainty. If they offered a lower
price, they'd still sell it with
certainty.
But what might the seller want to do?
What do we have to check?
Well, does the seller
actually want to sell it at price P
star?
Now, the issue is there's two types of
sellers. There's the high type seller
and the low type seller. We have to say
what is the strong the the more tempting
deviation. The issue we have to worry
about is and maybe I'll do separating on
another
page.
Um
Let's look at both cases.
The high type seller
is comparing
P star
- CH.
These are the two constraints.
If I'm a high type seller,
I could charge a price of P star,
and I sell at P star, but I have to pay
uh but my cost is CH, or I could set a
price that no one will buy at,
and therefore I get zero.
Conversely, if I'm the low type seller,
I could set a price of P star, pay my
cost, or I could sell at a really high
price that no one's going to buy at.
Which of these is harder to satisfy?
The top one, right? Because the high
type seller finds it more costly to
produce. So they might say this price P
star, it's not really worth it for me.
So this is going to be the binding
constraint. This is the critical the
important constraint.
And this is going to be the final
constraint that we need to impose.
Uh so what we need,
sort of
write it in words,
is
we need
VL
and CH
less than or equal to
P star
V star.
This inequality says the buyer is
actually willing to buy at a price of P
star.
This inequality says even when the
seller knows the good is high quality,
they're still willing to sell at a price
of P star.
And
the VL inequality is important because
if P star were less than VL,
then the seller could always slightly
raise the price, and the buyer would
still always have to buy.
Because we know the buyer always buys
when the price is below VL. So these are
kind of the three inequalities that we
get, and I think when you go through and
try to solve for PBE, this is sort of um
these are sort of the the steps you have
to go through.
Uh let me say just a little bit about
the separating equilibrium in the last 2
minutes.
So that was pooling.
Let's go down here to separating.
So for the separating equilibrium,
we now have PL not equal
to PH.
So when the seller knows the good is low
quality, they sell it at PL. When they
know it's high quality, they sell it at
PH. These are different.
As before, the buyer is choosing a
strategy Q
from zero infinity
to zero one.
Now, which prices are on path? It's both
PL and PH. So now let's look at beliefs.
If the buyer sees a price of PL, they
know that the seller is low quality.
So they assign probability
zero to H.
If they see PH,
they know the seller is high quality, so
they assign probability
one
to H.
And if they see any other price,
well, now their beliefs are flexible
because we can't apply base rule. This
is off path. So flexible.
And you know, we can go through and try
to do the same analysis. Maybe I'll just
say two kind of tricks here.
You might look Let me just say one final
thing. You might try to find an
equilibrium where the buyer buys at
price PL and at PH. I'm going to argue
that can't be an equilibrium. Why could
there not be an equilibrium where the
buyer buys when they see PL and buys
when they see PH? Why can't there be a
separating equilibrium where the buyer
always buys?
Think about the seller's incentives.
There are two prices at which the seller
always buys.
What would you do as the seller?
Well,
one of these is higher. Let's say PH is
higher. If you were the seller, you'd
always sell at PH
because you get more revenue and the
buyer is willing to buy.
So, it turns out there's not going to be
a separating equilibrium where the buyer
always buys. We're going to actually
have to have a mixed strategy where the
buyer buys with some probability
following PH, but you'll see how to how
to work through that
in the problem set.
But, let's make sure we understand the
intuition for that. Okay, let me stop
there. I'll see you all on Thursday.